es que se cumple el primer aniversario
del golpe de estado en mianmar que
derrocó a el gobierno democráticamente
electo a la líder civil a un sándwich y
el golpe me truncó diez años de
transición a la democracia siendo
solvente había decantado en elecciones
democráticas y el país volvió al régimen
militar vigente por décadas más de 1500
personas murieron y cerca de 12 mil
fueron arrestadas en este contexto de
las protestas entre ellos aún son su
chica y cumple seis años de sentencia
por crímenes imputados por la junta
militar en el poder además enfrenta
procesos que podrían sumar hasta 100
años de cárcel que son rechazados por
grupos de derechos humanos entretanto
los militares se extendieron por seis
meses más el estado de emergencia
argumentando que buscan así garantizar
entonces las elecciones democráticas en
el futuro vamos a ver si esto se va a
dar estas elecciones democráticas cuando
ellos estuvieron el poder por una manera
no democrática pero bueno para conversar
sobre esta situación en mianmar
saludamos a patricio giusto él es
consultor político docente universitario
y directo diagnóstico político en el
observatorio sino argentino gracias por
estar con nosotros patrice en directo
américa de frança 24 de preguntó
entonces cómo están bien mar un año
después de ese golpe militar
bueno hoy la verdad que lo que vimos fue
una situación bastante rara una suerte
de calma en las avenidas principales
pero esto tiene que ver con el terror
que ha impartido la junta militar en
este último tiempo
recordemos que bueno estamos cumpliendo
un año con una represión feroz que no
tuvo freno durante todo este lapso con
operaciones permanentes para capturar y
en muchos casos directamente asesinar
opositores no sólo en las grandes
ciudades sino con campañas también hacia
el interior del país sobre todo lo más
serio sucedido en la zona noroeste donde
están los principales bastiones de
resistencia de las fuerzas
populares de la defensa que sería el
brazo armado del frente político unido
que sería toda la oposición política que
fue desplazada de digamos del poder hace
un año así que la junta uno puedo decir
se ha logrado afianzar en el poder pero
a fuerza de una represión brutal y con
una ciudadanía que está cada vez más
confrontado en lo que podemos decir que
es una situación de guerra civil en este
con una suerte de calma que no sabemos
cuánto va a durar ahora patricio porque
tras diez años de reformas y elecciones
fue imposible sostener la democracia en
un país acostumbrado al autoritarismo
qué fue lo que pasó que fue lo que
detonó hoy digamos la figura de hans
anschütz y fue realmente algo verdadero
o fue algo que no fue tan tan real no a
ella la verdad que más allá de sus
buenas intenciones nunca terminó de
consolidarse como una líder democrática
plena recordemos que en el 2011 empieza
este proceso después de décadas de
dictadura recién en 2015 se puede
realizar esa elección donde ella es
consagrada posteriormente pero ella
nunca dejó de responder a las fuerzas
armadas no
fíjate que uno de los caminos de los
temas que a ella justamente le resta
prestigio y creo que termina haciendo
uno de los desencadenantes para su caída
por su férreo apoyo a la represión
brutal el genocidio de los rohingyas es
una etnia musulmana minoritaria que fue
masacrado y desplaza durante el gobierno
de un samsung y por eso ahí ella pierde
prestigio internacional y también queda
debilitada frente a una parte de la
sociedad importante de mianmar y bueno
después vienen unas elecciones donde el
partido de gobierno que ella encabeza
gana por más del 80 por ciento y la
junta de dijo basta hasta acá llegamos
no vamos a permitir que el proceso
democrático se siga afianzando y eso es
lo que termina sucediendo hace
exactamente un año
vos bien decías la junta acaba de probar
por seis meses el estado de emergencia
cualquier observador internacional que
tiene un poco de información sabe que
eso se va a seguir programando y que la
junta no tiene intenciones de dejar el
poder y de volver a encauzar un proceso
democrático si ahora patricio qué va a
pasar que una figura de anshan su chip
porque ella siendo ganadora del nobel de
paz porque ella queriendo ser digamos
una figura democrática que vele por los
derechos humanos pues digamos no entre
comillas hizo nada y como usted lo dijo
apoyo de alguna manera esta represión y
este genocidio contra los rohingyas ella
digamos esta presión por los militares
del país y si eso es cierto porque a lo
mejor no se hizo un lado para no tener
una imagen negativa no es que tú bien lo
dice siendo el nobel de la paz con todo
lo que ella tenía en términos de imagen
internacional está claro que ella podía
haber hecho otra cosa el problema es que
en alguna que otra entrevista ya de
contra ver que fue como una suerte del
mal menor si ella no apoyaba se tenía
que ir del poder y se hubiese
precipitado en ese momento el golpe
bueno el golpe terminó sucediendo igual
unos meses después y los rohingyas
fueron masacrados de a cientos de miles
y más de un millón de ellos están hoy en
condiciones infrahumanas en bangladesh y
en parte en la india así que terminó
siendo el mal menor finalmente no
sabemos bien obviamente es historia
contrafáctica pero el golpe terminó
sucediendo y la masacre se terminó
también cometiendo sobre el futuro de
ella muy complejo ya está acusada de
varios cargos de corrupción la mayor
parte de ellas obviamente una farsa
inventados por haber usado elementos de
comunicación que tenían prohibida en su
en su cautiverio bueno ya tiene unos
siete años de condena confirmados y si
se suman todos esos cargos puede llegar
hasta 80 años ochenta y nueve años de
condena algo que es ridículo pero bueno
lo que sabemos que en el corto plazo
esta mujer que ya tiene 76 años mientras
la junta militar esté en el poder no va
a ser liberada ha habido alguna
intervención que quiso hacer china para
visitarla hace uno de los pocos países
con lo que mianmar tiene relaciones y no
le permitieron así que es un futuro
realmente incierto el de esta mujer con
als anschütz y apartada digamos de la
vida política no hay otra figura que
pueda ayudar esos ánimos de democracia
en el país también patricio le quiero
preguntar entonces qué va a pasar con la
junta militar realmente si tienen la
disposición de querer hacer unas
elecciones democráticas y justas porque
mire que ya ha extendieron seis meses
más este estado de emergencia entonces
pues puede seguir prorrogando lo hasta
que nunca se hagan estas elecciones cuál
es cuál es su análisis sobre esto bueno
a mí mi análisis es que la junta tiene
pensado permanecer en el poder de alguna
forma de la evaluación que hacen los
generales es de generar me han y otros
que realmente lo secunda es que los diez
años de esa supuesta transición
democrática fueron un fracaso fueron un
retroceso para mí al mar y por ahora
ellos no están dispuestos entiendo a
reencausar el proceso respecto a las
figuras es un tema era una figura
absolutamente
preponderante de la de aung san suu kyi
realmente no no se perfila otra figura
de ese peso en la oposición que puede
encabezar un nuevo proceso democrático
con todo lo que eso implica después de
este retroceso jugueteras el escenario
de 2011 es un escenario mucho peor por
supuesto además pensemos en el impacto
económico en la economía está devastada
de mianmar se fueron un montón de
empresas hay inflación hay cortes
permanentes de energía internet la gente
vive en condiciones realmente muy
complejas y que cualquier proceso
democrático que venga en el futuro
cercano va a ser mucho más complejo y
sobre todo con el agravante de que no
hay una figura como de la talla de amd